[Music]
I think that we have a terrible
misconception about popularity I think
that often we define popularity in a
majoritarian way we say that in order
for something to be popular
most people have to like it a majority
of the population has to like it but
think about this if a book sells 1
million copies in a year it is a runaway
bestseller that by definition 99.5
percent of Americans did not buy the
biggest movie of 2016 robe 1 the Star
Wars film made enough money for about
forty thirty five to forty percent of
American adults to have bought a ticket
and seen it that means the vast majority
of Americans did not see the most
popular movie you could say the same for
television you could say the same for
music that lots of things that we
consider popular are not majority only
popular at all they aren't mainstream by
this old-fashioned definition instead
they are cults that culture itself is
cults from top to bottom it is
increasingly in this moment now where
the mainstream hasn't been completely
shattered and it's been totally niche if
I'd that culture is cults all the way
down and I think that in thinking about
this from a marketing standpoint and
you're thinking about your total
addressable market your total
addressable market is not America it's
not the world it's not any enormous
group of people your total dress full
market is probably really really small
and rather than go big with the general
message that you hope is going to
embrace everybody rather embrace the
idea that the mainstream is dead that
it's all cults and that you have to find
your call and hit them very very clearly
with the message that is cultish that
says you are special because the
mainstream is wrong remember that is the
definition of what cultish thinking is
it's a positive rebellion against an
illegitimate mainstream so in order for
people to feel like a message is
reaching them it helps for that message
to tell them not only who they are but
who they're not how they are different
how they're special and how the vast
majority
of people how the amorphous mainstream
doesn't get them I sometimes talk about
this is online in terms of online
marketing is the the Tokyo example I'm
gonna Tokyo two years ago and the friend
who was telling me about how awesome
Tokyo is said there's this great bar
that sells amazing Japanese whiskey and
also vinyl records and I was like what a
strange idea for a place to only sell
vinyl records and whiskey and he said
yeah it does sound weird but remember
that Jap that Tokyo is a metro area of
35 million people so even if the store
only applies to like 0.5% of the Tokyo
metropolitan population it's still an
incredibly popular store so the Internet
is Tokyo the Internet is this
infrastructure that is connecting
billions and billions of people and you
don't need to reach all of them all at
once in order to make something that's
popular in fact it makes much more sense
to try to reach 0.2 0.01% of them with a
message that is really clear and very
specific and very special and understand
that even if I get this microscopic
percentage of the total addressable
market to love what I'm doing
that is popularity
[Music]